foreign
a little bit close to the camera can you
see it okay
so
if
I hadn't of
had such a good teacher originally
and him
say to me I can't teach any more tony if
you need to if you want to advance and
you want more lessons then I suggest you
go to London
from London I got my black belts
met cytosensei become his
person for the UK
followed him until he passed away
um
once he passed away I searched around
because I I always feel that you should
keep contacts with other excuse me
like-minded people who are training also
only one like you know
so that you can you know exchange views
look at their Aikido see if that you're
slipping behind or
like one big family you know you do make
it more of a family thing
the longer you're in it
now
when I left
to go to Greece
I was rather annoyed that um some of my
students left in the way they left
so I decided to just go to Greece and
not be part of anybody for a short
period
because I'd gone I'd retired Built My
dojo and I would just do my seminars
people would come there from around the
world twice a year
and I was happy to do this and I would
issue the the standard
certificates for black belts
then in 2007 I decided got to do
something because
um
the Russian students and the Greek
students were saying that they did the
UK certificate wouldn't be recognized as
these two countries only had IQ Kai
and they were the ones recognized
so I joined the TAA in California
because
first and foremost I could have gone
direct to the ikikai humbu
that's you know they're separate okay so
I could have gone direct to Tokyo
asked the IQ car I was a sixth day and
so I was entitled to do it and I could
have dealt with them direct and I could
have issued the black belt certificates
I have blackmail certificates up to a
certain level scientists when he was
alive said I could issue up to fifth
down
I don't know if that's the same now or
not
so as far as I'm concerned that gave us
lots of scope
but
I was missing the camaraderie
people
and in the TAA the there was a group of
people that was from the same Dojo that
I first met when I used to go there
first one was for their teacher and one
was because cytos NC would go each year
and teach a seminar
and there
when uh this what the dojo
when this teacher would just say at the
moment went bad and wasn't able to teach
anymore because I was police inquiry
about him uh
Scentsy Hendricks invited him so it
continued I don't want to go on too much
about that but basically my the students
who were high ranks by this time
in 2007
there was a group of them that I liked
as friends so I thought I'd joined them
so I joined them
um I could award the ikikai ranks but
they would go through the organization
and so I got the best of both worlds
I gave them my word that I would
try and convert as many UK certified
teachers
students teachers who had who had UK
certification to ikikai some could
afford it some couldn't
so those who could we did and it still
left a majority who couldn't
so for since
2007 to 2022
this problem has plagued me
because every year I'm asked why can't
we convert more people or
I've been told you only joined us
because you wanted akikoe certification
that hurts me a lot and it it troubles
me a lot because psycho says he was
happy with
me awarding either one
he never put pressures on me
so
I've tried several ways of
doing this and I've given the six stands
in the organization the power to award
uh UK certification
Ultra Sun level
I have only been wanting to award ikikai
and therefore I created a my own Problem
by awarding ikikai
but rarely
it doesn't matter what piece of paper I
was awarding the person the person is
either good enough or not good enough
but in 2022
I was being tormented about
um
I'd got to make a decision on I'm
following an organization that I didn't
feel as if I fitted in anymore
through throat certain political reasons
I've been a sixth down for 20 years
and
I thought
perhaps who don't like me well I perhaps
I'll never get my seventh I'm not a
great Chaser or else I wouldn't be
bringing this up after 20 years
I'm committed to the art of Aikido
and still committed
and the point is
I had to make a decision
what am I going to do
so I went to talk to some senior people
from other organizations who are 100
ikikai certified
and to my amazement I found out that um
let's say I've awarded 200
black belts I could go black belts
some of them up to you know when I've
sent the money off for fifth dance
it's nine hundred dollars
and pound to the dollar at the moment
it's not so good so
let's say a hundred pound or so it's
still a vast amount of money isn't it
for a piece of very nice cardboard that
you'll put on the wall and
um
but you've had to be the one who's
answered
so
these people said well why don't you go
direct yourself
and I said yes I know I can do that but
I've always been bothered about being an
individual and they said well look all
the years you've been training why are
you still questioning it
and I thought yes this is my as a person
I might see I'm a positive person but
this is my insecurity
so I can
tell you all about the things I've done
but this is my insecurity and also I'm a
teacher and what about all those
hundreds of people that follow me and
rely on me
if I just say to them all of a sudden oh
there's no more okay kind they give you
a UK certification
I'm letting them down I was the one that
told them they've got to have ikikai
from 2007 and now I have like a guy
fifth dance
yeah all of a sudden you're not going to
have them because
I've decided perhaps not to bother with
them so so there
encouragement made it so I thought I
won't tell the teachers and students in
the organization what I should do is I
shall ask them how important
this is for them
and I've had a response and in my next
film I shall be giving you the the
figures and the facts and my decision
what I've come to
foreign
in all these years that what I didn't
know was let's say out of a fifth Dan
even a third or a second man I mean it's
a third down then at 300 and 350 400 or
whatever it is I know it's 900 for 50.
these people told me that half
kept by the person that sends the money
so I would
um I would keep
half of the nine hundred dollars
and this made me think back
and I thought wow
I thought that was expensive and I
really struggled
and when people said to me Sensei could
we have a UK certification
because I can't afford because it was
always half the money
I can't afford an I could kind one
I've got no answers I said but that's
the price that's the cost
where now I realized and quite through
these
people being very honest and genuine
that half the cost goes to the eikenkai
and half the cost so 250 dollars
sorry I
got a 450 dollars go to ikigai for 450
goes to the organizational person that
sends off the paperwork
I was absolutely astounded and here I am
a person over 70 years of age
gullible and naive to think that all the
money was going to Japan
so
it's a political money machine
the letters I've got back in saying oh I
need to be occupied because if I go
aboard I might not be able to train
in all the years that I've been in
Aikido nobody's ever refused me
it's a train at their dojo
let's say
you go somewhere
you say where you're from
they don't often ask your level but they
might ask your level you tell them
you're level they train they either say
thank you I had a great training
I've never ever anybody asked me whose
certification I've got
but it seems to nowadays be a worry and
a concern to the new newer black belts
and as a teacher as I said before it's a
responsibility that the teacher must
take on board and not be selfish for
themselves
this is something I've considered while
making these films
I wanted you to have some history and my
journey
and how hard it's been
and when I taught to cite a sense about
the loss of such high grade students I'm
up to fourth down that I've lost and
they've gone to other senses
you worry that perhaps you're not
teaching well enough perhaps you're not
a good teacher perhaps there's perhaps
you're saying things that aren't truths
but then when I can look back at the
films and the books
and prove that I am teaching what side
of sense he taught me but since he
taught him then I have lineage
I have a truth in my heart that I am
doing my best
and did they lose did they leave
for a different reason I have no idea
most of them tell me they're leaving
because I left them or they're leaving
um
I had a strange one once
I was told
they were leaving because I didn't allow
them
to be close to me as far I was asking
them to do things in the dojo
when organizing seminars now I didn't
ask for their help and they
saw others even though the others were
senior to their rank
they felt as if I wasn't giving them a
chance to be closer to me
so
so going back to our cytosmc and he said
many have left him
and look
of what he'd done and and his life with
our Sensei his life at running the Wilma
Dojo As a caretaker
he said they perhaps don't like my style
perhaps they feel I'm too hard on
he said
the biggest thing that he found was
they're not committed
they want to have Aikido the way they
want to have it
unless
and the way he
teaches or runs up his Aikido is just
too hard for them it's it demands too
much of them
and this will be my
summing up in my next film
of
my full circle and my decision
on whether
this year
we apply direct for ikikai
or whether we do UK certification
thank you for listening so far I hope
you're finding it of Interest